the sun shone on leith on tuesday night
the day scotland's first minister
illuminated the path ahead
at easter road arsenal's players minus
pike osaka
visited hibs for a pre-season friendly
in this crowd
on covert restrictions it's the scots
playing the longer game
we've got to start opening up we've got
people people have got to live with us
whatever it is
we've come too far to take chances on
going back
you'd rather be safe and not rushing
into it i suppose i think there's got to
be an air of
let's push out let's rebuild the economy
and get life going again because we
can't live like this forever
in a remote meeting of the scottish
parliament nicola sturgeon said next
monday
not
does we available say so we should do
what is necessary to ensure compliance
and we should be prepared to take any
resulting flack from those who disagree
we shouldn't lift important restrictions
to make our lives easier
and then expect the public to take
responsibility for doing the right thing
in a way it's not just a slap dash
approach to cleaning
it needs to be seen to be fair for
places like time twister soft play
the announcement means survival money
through the door after a 16-month
closure
the future of my business is now back in
our control at least to some extent
we've got a lot of work to do we've got
a lot of
ground to make up on what we've lost
over the last 16 months
but at the moment at least we're now in
a position to do something about it
airports north of the border had
appealed to the first minister
to align scotland with the rest of the
uk on easing quarantine requirements
watching the announcement they got it so
clearly that's a step in the right
direction and it's important that it's
an alignment with uk
policy i think that's really important
but we
we had five days which doesn't sound
very much between the two announcements
but it is
really meaningful in terms of what
airlines have decided to do in that
period
so we've seen significant amount of
investment of capacity into english
airports that we've not had
so we're playing catch up again and so
now we have an
idea of the pace of travel towards life
beyond covered restrictions but the
remain fundamental uncertainties
what happens when restrictions are
lifted how will the public react
and not least how does the virus respond
nicola sturgeon says the 9th of august
remains the planned date for lifting all
restrictions
but only if the data allows it is
scotland's next big fixture
but it's only penciled in for now james
matthews
sky news edinburgh